Welcome back to Curious Archive.
This video is a new chapter in my long-running
series exploring the incredible speculative
evolution saga of Serina, the world of birds.
Serina was created by the talented artist
and worldbuilder Dylan Bajda — and many
extraordinary developments have occurred since
we last explored this distant moon.
The triumphs and tragedies, the joys and the
sorrows of this era are perhaps greater than
any that have come before.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
chronicle the rise and fall of fascinating
species, and discover astonishing revelations
as the world of Serina creeps ever closer
to its end…
…Two-hundred and seventy million years since
the story began, we have now entered the Late
Ocean Age, an era where the encroachment of
ice is at its worst yet — with a shallow,
vegetated equatorial ocean now the last haven
for most species on Serina.
When we left off, the Gravediggers and Daydreamers
had joined forces and established a unified
society.
With the battle against the Warmongers becoming
a faint memory, these two species will create
a culture that will persist on a timescale
greater than any that came before.
Over the coming era, Gravediggers and Daydreamers
will transform the equatorial ocean into a
paradise.
With deep knowledge of the principles of ecology,
they become ecosystem engineers, carefully
influencing the evolution of other species
to ensure the environment remains stable.
And a third intelligent species has joined
their alliance, one descended from the earlier
Luddies, a playful herbivore species who have
been growing more and more intelligent.
And after millions of years of co-evolution,
the Luddies have now become the wise Greenskeepers.
Together, these three remarkable species — collectively
called the Sea Stewards, will influence the
path of all creatures that swim in this shallow
ocean.
One of the most extreme examples of a species
whose evolution has been shaped by the Sea
Stewards’ influence is the Floating Bloat.
Over 140 feet, or 42 meters in length, this
herbivore is the largest creature to evolve
on Serina, eclipsing the length and weight
of blue whales on Earth.
The Bloat is now so large that it is too buoyant
to fully submerge itself, instead floating
along like a boat with its elongated neck
dipping below the sea to feed on thousands
of pounds of vegetation per-day.
A semi-domesticated animal, the Floating Bloat
serves as a source of food and raw material
for the Sea Stewards, yet lives a life of
relative bliss.
Another species much changed by the Sea Stewards
presence are the Aukvultures.
A type of seraph, the Aukvultures are one
of the last descendants of the Archangles
that once ruled Serina’s skies.
Like Earth vultures, Aukvultures have converged
upon a scavenger niche, feeding off the scrap
piles of the Sea Stewards.
This behavior has caused the Aukvultures to
become unusually intelligent, able to manipulate
Gravediggers into offering them scraps by
performing simple tricks.
They’re a lineage to keep an eye on.
Within this engineered ecosystem, many species
remain wild.
One of the more fascinating keystone lineages
of this era are the Sealumps.
An offshoot of the Land Trunkos we’ve seen
in past eras, Sealumps managed to escape the
ice-scarred mainland to the lush underwater
Eden just beyond the shore.
Now a specialized marine subspecies, the Sealumps
have become a keystone lineage in the shallow
oceans.
One species seems more changed than any other.
The Sea Shoggoths, once mighty predators feared
by all, now function as a garbage disposal
service.
Fed by the Sea Stewards’ regular supply
of waste, these terrifying ant colonies have
learned not to attack the providers of their
consistent meals.
But the Sea Shoggoths have not been tamed
by this partnership.
They have only been made smarter.
The colonies know that for now, the path of
least resistance is waiting passively for
offerings of garbage.
But if this uneasy contract is ever terminated,
the Sea Shoggoths will not hesitate to do
whatever they need to survive…
Over the next several million years, Sea Steward
society remains remarkably unchanged, as the
foundations of their civilization are ecologically
sustainable and not inclined to technological
shifts.
And the ancient Daydreamer prophecy, which
told of three different essences of a deity
creator — land, water, and air — finding
each other once again, has now been largely
relegated to a myth.
In all their travels, Sea Stewards have never
encountered flying lifeforms with advanced
intelligence, so many assume the third essence
never existed after all...
Yet there are regions the Sea Stewards have
yet to chart.
Few species from the shallow sea venture past
the southernmost islands.
But this young Glacial Foxtrotter — the
last of the three-legged canithere lineage
— is about to stumble upon a forgotten land.
Crossing a newly-formed bridge of sea ice,
the Foxtrotter reaches the southern continent
of Serinaustra.
This frozen region is a wasteland, yet it
is not uninhibited.
A few creatures eke out their lives in Serina’s
least welcoming environment — like the fearsome
Snowscrounger.
These scavengers are the single living descendent
of the Squork, a tentacle-bird lineage that
hasn’t been as successful as the Trunkos
in adapting to the changing world.
The Snowscrounger’s presence makes life
on Serinaustra an uneasy prospect for the
lone Foxtrotter.
Against all odds though, it will establish
a place here—and will not be the last Foxtrotter
to do so...
Yet Serinaustra isn’t the only frozen wasteland
on Serina.
Its northern counterpart, the continent of
Serinarcta, is home to a long-lost relative
of the ocean-going Gravedigger.
The Savage Gravediggers are hulking predators
that lost the spark of sapience in favor of
physical strength.
Rumors of these monsters form the basis of
campfire stories among the ocean-going Gravediggers,
although few believe the stories to be true...
And there is another remarkable species on
Serinarcta that has slipped the detection
of the Sea Stewards.
The Blue-Tailed Chatteravens are a territorial
and often aggressive omnivore species that
are nonetheless abnormally intelligent.
For the Chatteravens are the descendants of
the White-Margined Chatterers — a species
notable for being the pet of the Last Woodcrafter.
And the Chatterers are, in turn, distantly
evolved from the Babbling Jays — the first
advanced intelligent life to emerge on Serina
for a brief time all those eons ago.
In the present, Chatteravens are intelligent
enough to possess a rudimentary language,
but none of them are truly sapient.
That is, except for one.
Brighteye is a young chatterraven with a rare
mutation that allows for abstract thinking
and imagination.
He is a genetic throwback, having regained
the spark of his ancestral species.
And he isn’t the only mutant in his family.
His brother, whose name translates to Whitecrown,
was born an outcast due to his lack of pigment.
Unwelcome within the brutal Chatterraven hierarchy,
the two siblings set off on their own across
Serinarcta.
While isolated in this harsh wilderness, they
at least have each other.
And Brighteye has seen things he can’t explain
to his younger brother.
Visions of species he doesn’t recognize,
and whispers from a mysterious voice telling
him he’s not alone.
And though neither knows it yet, the actions
of Brighteye and Whitecrown will change Serina
for millions of years to come.
Many dangers await the brothers in the snowy
wilds of Seinarcta.
On silent, fur-lined wings, the startling
Snowspirit stalks prey like a vengeful ghost.
The ice-age descendant of the early-ultimocene
tribbats, Snowspirits fortunately rarely go
for prey larger than rats.
Like barn owls, they are nocturnal hunters,
and have convergently evolved a facial disc
to improve their hearing.
In the winter darkness, spotting a Snowspirit’s
large, expressive eyes is a frightening sight.
Yet there are larger predators than Snowspirits.
Scissorjaws — the last species of the once
thriving circuagodogs (sir-quaggo-dogs) — are
hunters with asymmetrical jaws capable of
bringing down large predators.
The Scissorjaws, though, are on the absolute
brink of extinction.
For they are being systematically hunted by
a force they cannot hope to understand.
While journeying across the ice, the brothers
encounter the body of a fallen Scissorjaw.
While Whitecrown takes the free meal without
question, Brightyeye can’t help but wonder:
what kind of predator hunts without eating
their prey?
Soon, the brothers find the answer.
A wooly giant roams not far from the fallen
Scissorjaw.
Brighteye recognizes it as a plant eater,
and, more-remarkably, notices what appears
to be a tool in its trunk-like beak.
And when their eyes meet, Brighteye recognizes
something else — the spark of intelligence.
This is a Wolly Wumpo, the largest living
land animal of this age, and one of the most
intelligent.
At long last, sapience has struck within the
tentacle bird lineage.
The Wooly Whumpos possess a unique language
and can use tools, but they are fearful of
outside dangers, eliminating the Scissorjaws
due to the potential threat they posed.
And Wumpos have good reason to be wary.
Not only are their numbers few, but they are
sometimes hunted by none other than the Chatteravens.
On their own, a flock of Chatteravens has
no hope of taking down a Wumpo, but they have
a grim hunting strategy.
By singing in eerie harmony, they can alert
large predators to the location of lone Wumpos
— and then feed on any scraps left behind.
But Brighteye isn’t like most Chatteravens.
Through silent gestures, he is able to convince
the Wumpo — an elder whose name roughly
translates to ‘Blaze’ — that he means
her no harm.
And what’s more, Brighteye is able to indicate
his intelligence.
From here on out, their lives are intertwined.
Convincing the other Wumpos that the two Chatteravens
aren’t a threat isn’t an easy task for
Blaze, as their society has long been fearful
of outsiders.
But Blaze knows that, somehow, these Chatteravens
are special.
Communication between such separate lineages
isn’t easy, as Brighteye can’t register
most of the sounds that make up the Wumpo
language.
But like the Gravediggers and Woodcrafters
long before them, they find a way.
Through the use of symbolic drawings, Brighteye
and Blaze break down the communication barrier
— inventing a unique language of pictograms.
Soon, other Whumpos learn to do the same,
and a new world of possibilities opens up
between them…
At the same time, the Sea Stewards have come
to a grim realization that all other species
on Serina are blissfully unaware of: The planet
is freezing over, and soon the ocean will
be uninhabitable.
But if there’s anything the Sea Stewards
excel at, it’s cooperation towards a common
goal.
And there are rumors that the Gravediggers
of the northern coasts have discovered something
beneath the ground that might help.
Traveling to the north, the Stewards discover
vast deposits of peat and coal.
Formed from remains of ancient tropical swamps,
these deposits also house the bones of huge
and terrifying animals that roamed across
Serina millions of years ago.
Transporting these materials to the southern
ice sheets requires an engineering project
of an unmatched scale, but the Stewards are
determined to save the sea.
Transporting thousands of tons of material
to the expanding glaciers and setting them
ablaze, the Stewards begin to experience some
success.
But the region their mines are located in
is a perilous one, home to the monsters of
their myths — demons that look like they
do, but attack without mercy.
Their project cannot be completed quickly
enough…
Yet unbeknownst to the miners, they are being
watched.
Brighteye is curious about these new arrivals,
but Blaze sees them as monsters.
For there is a legend that all Wumpos know,
that tells of an evil that came from the sea.
Generations prior, the Gravediggers made landfall
and began to hunt the Wumpos — not recognizing
their intelligence.
In retaliation, one Wumpo stole fire from
the Gravediggers to drive them back — but
couldn’t control the wild substance, and
caused the destruction of the herd and themselves.
Now, all Wumpos fear the Gravediggers — and
the fire they command.
But Brighteye isn’t convinced.
He believes the fire could be an asset to
the Wumpos and himself, if only they could
learn to make it.
And as a descendent of a speech-mimicking
bird, through careful practice, he is able
to ask the Gravediggers directly how they
make fire.
One can only imagine how the first Gravediggers
reacted to hearing a talking bird — a scene
right out of their oldest prophecy.
And unbeknownst to Brighteye, his actions
will ignite more than just coal…
Word of a talking bird spreads like wildfire
among the Sea Stewards.
At last, the prophecy seems to be upon them—the
third essence of their deity—the wings—having
seemingly arrived.
So, when Brighteye asks the Sea Stewards to
give fire to the Wumpos and leave them in
peace, who are they to say no?
The Steward’s engineering project is nearly
complete, and with the danger of ice on the
decline, sharing fire seems like little consequence.
And far away, a presence watches all this
unfold.
Some of what it sees impresses the observer,
yet other things have it worried.
With the mass-extraction of coal, a Pandora's
box was now open.
For the first time in 270 million years of
its observation, something has arisen within
the project that has the potential to destroy
it.
Time passes.
The Wumpos use the gift of fire to drive back
any predators that threaten the herd.
Whitecrown eventually departs, guided by instinct
to return to the wild.
In time, Blaze departs too, the elder Wumpo
passing away peacefully.
Brighteye mourns his loss, and becomes increasingly
frustrated with the strange expectations of
the Sea Stewards.
Then, to his horror, Brighteye discovers a
growing wildfire sweeping across the land.
The Chatteravens, following the example of
his brother Whitecrown, have learned to use
fire to hunt — but they can’t control
it.
The fire spreads to an underground coal seam,
and an apocalyptic chain reaction begins.
Like the ancient Wumpo who thought they could
control fire, Brighteye now realizes the depths
of his mistake.
In perhaps the greatest tragedy in all of
Serina’s history, the inferno spreads for
miles across the land, all the way to the
sunset.
And so, this chapter of the world ends not
with ice, but with fire.
From miles away, the Sea Stewards can see
the fire too, and know their world is coming
to an end.
And from far away, the observer, the one who
has overseen this experiment since the beginning,
feels something it isn’t supposed to feel.
It feels guilty.
By whispering to Brighteye that he was not
alone all those years ago, it interfered,
and now everything had fallen apart.
Dying on a smoldering beach, Brighteye hears
the observer’s voice again.
It apologizes for all the suffering its curiosity
caused.
But Brighteye doesn’t care, and with his
last breath, he spits a curse at his creator…
On the southern iceshelf, a lone Snowscrounger
notices the sky glows a brilliant orange.
It has no way of knowing a global apocalypse
is consuming Serina.
But the observer knows what is to come, just
as it knows everything that came before.
Over the course of Serina’s history, the
observer has witnessed many tragedies.
Seen many brilliant sparks go out, and never
has it interfered.
Yet this tragedy was the indirect result of
its own meddling, and as the observer reflects
on the last living moments of one brave little
bird, it makes a decision it has never before
made.
To offer help.
Appearing to the surviving Sea Stewards as
an amalgamation of many sapient species, the
observer speaks.
It tells them their world is ending because
of the consequences of the choices it made.
So now, it is giving them a choice.
The Sea Stewards can go to a planet just like
the one they know, except where the fire never
happened, and the ice will not close in.
So that one far and distant day their descendants
will swim across a far wider sea (stars).
The Sea Stewards accept.
The Sea Stewards awaken to a calm night, having
forgotten all they have seen.
To them, nothing has changed, and not a moment
has passed.
The observer has solved its conundrum — splitting
off the sea stewards and cloning their familiar
world to colonize a new project as a compromise
for its interference.
On this new world, the Sea Stewards’ culture
is now free to advance…
Yet far away, back on Serina, the experiment
isn’t over yet.
With the observer returning to its impartial
surveillance, Serina is left to see through
another mass extinction on its own.
With its major keystone species effectively
gone in an instant, the consequences will
be severe as Serina at last closes the door
on one chapter, and enters its final age…
Six hours into the Late-Ultimocene, the dawn
rises on a world without the Sea Stewards.
Ravenous Nimicorn Thorngrazers feed on the
bodies of animals claimed by the fire, which
continues to burn through the coal seams beneath
the earth.
In time, the Sea Shoggoths — no longer provided
with regular meals, will revert to their ancestral
condition.
And so, Serina enters a wild era where for
now only the toughest living things will be
rewarded.
The mighty bloats are one of the first species
to vanish from this new world.
With no natural defenses against horrors like
the Sea Shoggoths, they make for easy targets.
In just a few centuries, only the skeletons
of these mighty oceanic titans remain.
As Serina warms and the ice melts, the oceans
grow deeper, and decaying plant life adapted
for the shallows turns the seas toxic — resulting
in almost 95% of ocean life becoming extinct.
On land, a great thaw has begun.
Duck-billed sealumps — the only sealump
species still capable of walking — arrive
in large numbers on Serinaustra, fleeing the
collapsing oceanic ecosystem.
The Foxtrotters that arrived here just five
centuries ago find food is more plentiful,
as do the Snowscroungers.
In Serinarcta, the ice has also retreated,
allowing for a rise in biodiversity.
Yet the loss of the glaciers brings forth
its own dangers.
Millions of years of built-up ice exerted
an extreme force upon Serina's crust, creating
concentrated subsurface pockets.
With the pressure now relieved, the plains
have been transformed into a deadly minefield.
Over the coming eons, volcanoes will come
to life after tens of millions of years of
dormancy, which will result in even more rapid
warming.
Yet Serina, eventually, begins to heal.
Several millennia later, there are few visible
signs of the Sea Stewards civilization left,
with the occasional exception of a Gravedigger
knife or a shard of pottery exposed through
erosion.
Their legacy though, has left one final mark
on Serina.
The Aukvulture — always an intelligent species
that learned to perform tricks in exchange
for food — has evolved to be even smarter
now that they must fend for themselves.
Most Aukvultures are highly intelligent for
an animal.
But among a small population — which refer
to themselves as reapers — a fluke of nature
has caused the spark of Sapience to arise
once more.
The reapers are a spiritual, melancholy group
who know their kind is not likely long for
this world.
Yet one reaper, whom we will call Eve, will
play a central role in a story unlike any
other...
The story begins in the atmosphere above Serina.
Something that looks like a comet from the
surface is circling the moon.
Two pods detach and crash-land on the ground,
sustaining heavy damage.
These mysterious probes are perhaps the first
new stimulus to enter the closed system of
Serina in over 270 million years.
Losing connection to the host satellite, they
are now very much alone.
One of these bizarre probes sets out from
the crash site, searching for the other.
From the sky, the reaper known as Eve watches
the strange star-creature with curiosity.
She’s never seen anything like this being
that moves like a living thing, yet doesn’t
seem to be alive.
Soon, the autonomous probe finds their sibling
has not survived the crash.
They will have to explore this strange world
all on their own.
But Eve follows the being, which she names
Fellstar, on their journey across the uncharted
surface.
For she is alone as well — having not seen
another intelligent Reaper in over a decade.
At first, Fellstar spends their time cataloguing
the world around them with mechanical indifference.
But in time, they take notice of Eve, who
points out native species to the curious robot.
Over time, Fellstar’s personality grows
bigger, and they learn to communicate with
Eve through gestures and imitation.
Across the widest chasms, they forge an unbreakable
bond.
Two lonely souls, isolated by space and by
time, ultimately find whatever they need in
each other.
They travel for many seasons, and find there
is much to live for.
Eventually, Fellstar no longer seems to remember
how - or why - they came here.
The story never directly states what kind
of intelligent life made Fellstar, but given
their avian appearance and gentle nature,
it seems likely Fellstar is an emissary from
the Sea Stewards planet.
While the Sea Stewards no longer remember
Serina, and having lost contact with Fellstar
might never find it again, the possibility
that their civilization is out there thriving
somewhere in the stars is a comfort after
so much devastation.
Yet eventually, everything — no matter how
extraordinary – must come to an end.
One might assume that Fellstar would last
beyond Eve, or perhaps beyond everything.
But while Fellstar doesn’t age or require
rest, they are not immortal.
Like most machines, Fellstar isn’t built
to function forever.
And so, they simply fall apart: piece by piece,
bit by bit, over the years, like a skeleton
on the plains.
While Fellstar doesn’t mind, Eve does, using
scavenged parts to keep their dear friend
functioning long past their natural ‘lifespan.’
While both of them know Fellstar’s end is
near, they make every day the best they can
— exploring new regions and cataloging new
species.
When no easy fixes remain, and Fellstar can
no longer travel, Eve brings specimens directly
to Fellstar instead.
Small comforts to take their mind off the
enviable.
Eve is prepared to take care of Fellstar forever,
but she knows they don’t want this.
Fellstar doesn’t fear the end of their journey
like organic creatures do.
In the end, Fellstar gestures for Eve to sit
beside them, and they spend one final moment
together.
When the spark that is Fellstar finally goes
out, all that is left is a cold shell.
Eve knows that her friend is gone.
She knows Fellstar’s body will stay where
it lies, untouched by animals and plants,
slowly falling apart into fragments, but never
truly vanishing.
It’s not a sight she can bare to see.
So, not knowing what else to do, she moves
on.
Reapers typically embrace solitude, but Eve
soon finds that being alone is not the same
as being lonely.
In time, she realizes that Fellstar would
want her to keep exploring.
To see what else is still out there, beyond
the world they walked together.
So, she decides to keep the adventure alive
in memory of her friend, and continue the
pursuit of discovery…
Setting out on her own, Eve has been forever
changed through her time with Fellstar, and
seeks to be a benevolent force in an uncaring
world.
She adopts an orphaned Foxtrotter, whom she
rears to adulthood as if it were her own child.
And in time, she discovers other intelligent
Reapers like her, and becomes part of their
flock.
And so Fellstar, in life and death, is a catalyst
for change within Eve, expanding her worldview,
and continuing an ancient chain of ideas shared
from one species to another, even after the
Sea Stewards have long left Serina.
Eve’s flock might very well be the last
group of Reapers under the sun, but they face
their fate head on.
For in the words of the author, everything
has its beginning, and so too everything has
its end.
But until that time, they will not stop living.
They won't give up.
One never knows how long their story might
be, but the world is wide, and life is full
of surprises…
The story of Serina isn’t over yet.
The End Ultimocene — an era home to some
of the most unique lifeforms of all — is
just beginning.
But that’s all I can give away for now.
If you find this project as incredible as
I do, I’d encourage you to check out the
main website linked in the description and
read more of Dylan Bajda’s incredible project
of Serina.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.